hi
my name is callum barnes from google
cloud i'm the product manager
for cloud speech and today i'm going to
be talking about measuring and improving
speech checks accuracy
with the google cloud speech product
first i'm going to give you a little bit
of an overview on cloud speech to text
then i'm going to talk about how you can
measure
the accuracy of speech to text on
your own data then what you can do using
our tools
to improve that accuracy once you've
measured it
and finally i will do a quick worked
example at the end
and link you out to some of the
companion tools and examples that we've
created
to go with this next on-air presentation
so google cloud speech to text is a
api which accepts audio it identifies
speech within that audio and returns the
text representation of that speech
this happens in real time or in batch
mode
we support both in all 71 languages
in 127 local variants that we support
we also have for each one of these
languages a massive vocabulary that goes
far beyond the dictionary
covers local vernacular proper nouns etc
today we're going to be especially
focused on the tools that we have
for customizing the api and improving
recognition on specific terms
as well as doing things like changing
the output formatting
so let's jump in and start talking about
speech accuracy accuracy is pretty much
the most important thing when it comes
to speech to text so whether you're
doing post processing on the text to
determine someone's intent and extract
entities or displaying the text directly
to users like for captions
uh having a higher quality transcript
that's more accurate
is going to result in a better user
experience either way
there are a whole number of factors that
can affect speech accuracy from
background noise to audio quality to
various different
accents or strange verbalizations and
all of these things can have a big
impact
at google cloud and google as a whole we
have tried to make our models
as robust as possible and this means
that they should work really really well
right out of the box on
a wide variety of types of speech and
other scenarios
but all speech recognition systems are
very sensitive to input data and that
means when you think about accuracy
you really need to be thinking about
what is the accuracy of this system on
my specific data
in my recorded environment the types of
speakers i have the types of speech it
is
and to do that you have to measure it
and to measure it
we need to have a common language for
how we talk about what the quality level
is
and in speech to text usually that's a
word
error rate or wer
wer or word error rate is not the only
way to measure speech accuracy
but it certainly is the most common and
even if you're also looking at other
metrics which can be valuable
usually they're looked at in conjunction
with word error rate as well
word error rate is composed of three
different types of errors that can
happen during transcription
one is the number of insertions so these
are words which are
present in the hypothesis or the machine
generated
in this case transcript that are not
present in the actual ground truth
accurate transcript
substitutions are the number of words
which are
present but are mistranscribed as a
different word
or formatted in an incorrect way
and finally deletions are the number of
words which are completely missing from
the hypothesis transcript which are
supposed to be present
in the source audio or ground truth
transcript you add up
all three of these numbers and you
divide by the total number of words that
exist in the ground truth reference
and that gives you the overall word
error rate
this means that it is actually possible
for a word error rate to be greater than
100
in situations where you have very very
poor quality
so to measure word error rate uh we have
a few steps you can follow and we've
also created a bunch of tools to make it
as easy as possible
but it all starts with getting your
audio files like i said before
if you want to measure accuracy and how
the system is going to perform
in how you're using it you must have in
domain
you know audio which is similar to what
you're going to be doing
generally we recommend having about
three hours in this test set
but you can still get pretty
statistically significant results with
as little as 30 minutes
of of in domain audio it's more
important that the audio
is similar and representative of what
you're trying to transcribe
than it is to have a ton of it
the second step is probably the hardest
of all of them you have to get the
ground truth for this audio so this
means you must have the
you know human transcribed 100 or as
close to 100
as possible accurate uh version of the
transcribed audio in order to compare
the various hypotheses against
the third step is easy you get your
machine transcription by sending it to
the cloud speech api
and then finally you can compute the
word error rate with
our simple word script where you feed in
the hypothesis and the ground truth and
we will show you what the word error
rate is
that script in addition to telling you
the number of insertions deletions
and substitutions will also uh give you
this pretty printed html that will show
you
exactly where each error is and what
type of error it is
and you can see a sample of that here so
now that you've measured the accuracy of
your audio
it's time to think about what you can do
to improve that accuracy
on your test set and on your wider set
and we do this with a
set of tools that allow us to help
customize the model or customize the
system towards the type of audio that
we're sending
broadly speaking there's three different
ways to think about
improving speech accuracy through model
customization
the first is to customize the model to
your domain by providing contextual
information
an example of this would be if you knew
that people were going to be talking
about pizza or ordering pizza
uh you could bias towards you know
different types of cross different types
of cheese different toppings etc
next is to tweak weights to address
specific word or phrase
issues so commonly this can occur with
proper nouns people's names or maybe its
individual product names
but words which generally speaking occur
very rarely
in all speech number three
is to use context that you have to bias
towards specific types of information or
specific situations
so for example if you had a phone
system ivr you might know that a user is
about to tell you an account number or a
phone number and you can tell the asr
system to
only look for a digit sequence or
alphanumeric sequence
we support doing all three types of
these customizations
in google cloud speech through the use
of
our speech adaptation tools these tools
if used correctly can be extremely
powerful
and can shift quality very significantly
depending on the situation
and the type of biasing which you're
doing before we get into the features of
speech adaptation and exactly how to use
them though
i want to talk a little bit about how
speech adaptation works and how that's
somewhat different from
other types of model customization in
order to talk about how
we customize the model and customize the
results we need to understand
a little bit more about how asr or
automatic speech recognition systems
work
now this is a extremely simplified
diagram
and not all speech recognition systems
work in this exact same way
but it will help us illustrate the point
here so a very simple system would take
audio input in from a user into what's
called an acoustic model the acoustic
model
looks at the audio waveforms or the
spectrogram
and it converts these waveforms into
sounds which it thinks are there
also known as phonemes the language
model
then looks at the groupings and series
of phonemes
and tries to understand from those
sounds
which words or phrases are being said
most language models also take
context and other factors into account
when
determining uh the text which the
phonemes represent
some models will produce a single output
or perhaps it will have
n best alternatives uh that could be
determined from that grouping of
phonemes
now let's take a look at the simplified
version of the
google speech-to-text api
the audio comes into an acoustic model
and is a
uh converted to phonemes that are sent
to the language model just like we
talked about before
the difference is two things one is the
language model
produces instead of just a single
highest confidence hypothesis
or a series of and best alternatives
but it produces an entire lattice
of potential word alternatives the other
difference
is the speech adaptation api which
allows users to send
context and word hints about what the
audio might contain
this information is then used to operate
on the word lattice and determine based
on these hints
as well as the confidences from the
language model
what the highest confidence hypothesis
text is
as well as and best alternatives if
that's interesting too
this differs slightly from other types
of model customization where you might
have a custom language model where the
entire language model itself
is changed to account for specific
proper nouns
or various different sequences which
might be expected
but the great part about speech
adaptation is there's no training or
retraining required so it's much easier
to experiment
uh and much cheaper to adapt the model
to a variety of different needs
next is it happens completely in real
time so we're
able to compute these changes without
adding any latency to
the end-to-end asr pipeline
and this also means because there's no
training and it happens in real time
you can have a different context with
every single request that you send
so one request can bias towards a digit
sequence and the next request can
bias towards somebody's name for example
all of this can be
accomplished with the speech adaptation
api that i was talking about before the
speech adaptation api today
has three different components or
options first
is phrase hints this is the ability to
send words or
long phrases which you think may be
present in the speech or in the text
and the system will do its best to look
at the words and combinations
of words biased towards that particular
piece of information
in some cases though that might not be
enough or might not be giving you
granular enough control
and that's what the boost api is for the
boost api
allows you to specify an actual weight
value
for a specific word or bigram that will
then take effect on that word or bigram
in the word lattice this is especially
useful for things like proper nouns
or rare words because you can
significantly
boost the likelihood of them being
recommended finally we have the classes
feature
which is essentially pre-built phrase
hints and boost values
for common scenarios for example an
alphanumeric sequence or a digit
sequence
being able to uh
recognize that without having to set the
values yourself
coming soon uh we'll have some additions
to the speech adaptation api
namely uh custom classes which will
allow users to
create and share their own pre-made
classes
that can then be used with boost or
speech adaptation the same way classes
can today
this doesn't make the system necessarily
any more accurate but it gives users
much greater composability when they
are working on these problems in the way
that they can specify
phrases or words that they want to bias
towards
next is save context which allows you to
save one or many known good biasing
configurations
and specify that entire phrase list or
boost list
with just an id on subsequent calls
this can be very useful in saving
bandwidth overhead uh for users that
need to send thousands or tens of
thousands of
words in each context
so that gives you an overview of the
biasing tools
and the model customization tools that
we have available
within the google speech api we're
always trying to improve these
but ultimately these tools
are just how you send and how you give
the biasing information
the real hard part is figuring out what
the right biasing information to send to
the api
is and that's what we're going to talk
about next
so broadly some things to consider are
what am i doing with this transcript so
when you are transcribing the audio is
the
result going into some nlu system where
you need to extract an entity
is it being displayed directly to a user
are there
specific things that the downstream
systems are going to be sensitive to
if your goal is to capture a phone
number then you have to be absolutely
positive that you're getting that digit
sequence right every single time
next thing to consider is are there rare
words or proper nouns
rare words and and proper nouns are very
difficult for asr systems because
statistically speaking they occur
very very uncommonly in everyday speech
so it's less
likely that a speech-to-text system is
going to
recommend that that is the word in the
series of phonemes as opposed to
a homonym of a more common word
this can be complicated but this is why
biasing towards these words very very
highly
can cause them to be recommended at the
rate which you want
the next is what contextual information
uh can i use so this is what external
information
outside of the audio itself can i use to
figure out
what the person might be talking about
so examples of this would be
you know context or state in a chatbot
application
maybe you have a user history so you
know the types of queries that the user
usually makes and you can use that to
help increase accuracy on future queries
and that feeds into the final point
which is do i have strong or weak
context so when you think about that
contextual information that you have
you should be thinking about do i know
exactly
what the user is going to say and i'm
pretty sure i know how they're going to
verbalize it
or do i just know sort of broad
categories of what this is about
some examples of strong context would be
a ivr like a phone
answering bot scenario where you know
exactly that the user is about to give a
phone number
or say yes or no or something like that
next would be
a system for giving commands or in a
like system
where you know that the user is going to
say change the channel
or play songs by some artist
in these systems you have very very
constrained vocabulary
and this can help you to bias and
increase accuracy on that specific
vocabulary
and finally as i talked about before
important words are entities
uh if you have a proper noun that's very
important to transcribe correctly
you're almost always going to need to
bias towards it very very strongly
next we have weak context which is
a situation like captions or
dictation or perhaps a conversation
between two people or multiple people in
a meeting
and these are situations where you don't
know exactly what somebody's going to
say
at any one moment but you know broadly
what they are talking about
for example this recording is all about
speech to text technology
and that might give you hints about what
words are going to be said
or or are common that you can use to
increase accuracy on those words
so now that we've looked at the biasing
tools that are available
as well as what to think about when
you're starting to think about biasing
and model customization
i'm going to take you through a demo or
really more of a worked example
on what it looks like to do biasing
for real now this is going to be a very
simple example we've also created
a bunch of content to go along with this
next on air session
where you'll actually be able to try all
of this for yourself in a quick lab
for the purpose of this demo i'm going
to be focusing on uh improvement type 2
that i talked about
where we're going to tweak weights to
address specific words and phrase issues
especially focused on
rare words and proper nouns as you'll
see
so to get started here i'm going to do
basically exactly what i told you not to
do before which is
i'm going to give this example based on
just one phrase and one sentence i don't
have a whole corpus of audio here
but the goal is not necessarily to
you know vastly improve this one phrase
but to just show you how i think about
the biasing problem
and the signals that you can use and
apply to a larger corpus
when you're doing this yourself or
trying it out in the quick lab
so i've recorded a single sentence of me
speaking here that i'll play for you
hi this is calum talking about the
spikotron
so you can see i say my name um a proper
noun
as well as a totally made up word
speakatron
now even with these rare words like i
said the google recognizer works very
well out of the box
so i actually didn't have any issues
recognizing this audio
originally so i had to make the problem
a little bit harder for our speech
recognition system
and to do that i added some noise to
this same audio recording
and this is the audio recording i'll be
using for
all the future examples in the demo so
i'll play that for you now
hi this is calum talking about this
ecotron
so as you can see exact same sentence
with some white noise added in the
background that made it
uh so that the asr system wasn't
recognizing it right out of the box
on the right hand side i've set up some
python code to try out sending this
to the cloud speech recognizer i've
specified my input file
i'm using us english since i'm a
american english speaker
this file is a basic linear pcm
wav file uh recorded at 16 kilohertz
i'm not sending any speech context yet
because i just want to see what the bare
usage of the system is next i need to
set up my simple word
script so i'm putting in my ground truth
hypothesis here hi this is callum
talking about the speakotron i haven't
included any punctuation in this case
but you could include punctuation if
you're expecting punctuation in the
result as well
the hypothesis will come directly from
the google speech transcript that i just
set up
and then we will compute the error rate
and and pre-print the html so let's take
a look at what the accuracy looks like
right out of the box on this noisy
i had a word error rate of 37.5 percent
driven all by substitution error here so
we can see it got my name wrong
uh not that wrong but it is spelled
incorrectly
um but more concerning instead of the
spikotron
it was transcribed as this ecotron
which is not good if we were really
worried about the spikotron product here
then we would have not even captured
that this phrase was about the spikotron
product
so let's look at what we can do using
the phrase him api
uh i could do something very simple like
put the exact right transcription in as
a phrase
hi this is callum talking about the
spikotron
now uh this did work this did result in
zero percent word error rate and the
phrase being
uh transcribed perfectly this is always
a good thing to try out if you have a
single phrase
um you know it basically just shows you
that speech adaptation as tools work
uh we are actually operating on the
lattice and changing things
but this isn't that helpful to you as
you think about improving
um recognition across an entire corpus
because if you knew
what the correct transcription of the
phrase was you wouldn't be sending it to
the speech api to begin with
so i don't think this is that helpful
and sending the whole phrase is also not
going to be helpful to
other words where somebody is saying hey
this is some other name
or they are verbalizing the phrase a
little bit differently
so let's think about what we can do to
increase recognition without just going
for the
full uh phrase being accurate
we could use the boost api and look at
the rare words like i talked about doing
before
calum and spikotron here are the two
rare words
and by boosting them fairly
significantly i think we can get pretty
good results
on on those words so let's take a look
at how
that performed on our noisy version of
the audio
i was able to decrease the word error
rate substantially just by doing this
where i've got it to spell my name
correctly now and
instead of ecotron it has correctly
recognized spikotron but there is still
an error of
it actually thinks it's saying this
specotron and not the speakertron
uh now this is an easy fix on on the
phrase side too
but it got me thinking more broadly
about what you can do to
increase this not just for this one
phrase but all phrases that are talking
about the spikotron
or that are talking about some you know
somebody saying their name is callum
and one thing we can do with boost is
to boost not just the unigrams that are
important to us but also the bi-grams
we wouldn't want to boost really
anything more than a bigram because
you're just going to significantly
confuse the lattice since
those phrases are never going to exist
like that in the lattice
but by thinking about you know how what
are the bigrams where people are going
to actually use these rare words we can
greatly increase recognition
so when somebody's saying their name
they're usually going to say
is name you know my name is callum or
this is callum
and you could also think of other
verbalizations
um and when i thought about spikotron i
thought people are probably going to say
the speakatron or
a uh the article with it basically
and we can use that to boost those
bi-grams
as well as the unigrams even more
strongly and that's going to help us get
even better recognition
uh in some of those scenarios and so in
this case i've boosted the bi-gram and
the unigram
i've chosen boost values of 5 and 10.
i think you'll have to play with exactly
what boost value works
best for you but generally speaking the
bigram with the article should be
boosted at a lower rate than
the unigram because you wouldn't want
every single
word after the to be transcribed as the
speaker drum
uh and with that i was able to actually
get down to zero percent word error rate
uh and we have an accurate transcript
like i said this is just working on one
single phrase
and you would never get to zero percent
word error rate on an entire corpus or
multiple different
variations on on this same phrase but
hopefully this gives you a helpful idea
about
the way to think about these problems
and what you can do to
overall decrease word error rate across
a corpus
so if you are interested in trying this
out for yourself or finding out more
information about
improving speech accuracy for your data
you can check out our docs we've
recently updated the speech adaptation
documentation to include a number of the
best practices that i just talked about
here
if you want to actually try it out for
real we've created a quick lab
specifically to go along with this
content called measuring and improving
speech accuracy
where you can try out using the
simple word script and tuning the
biosane with boost and phrase hints and
classes
and try to achieve the greatest word
error rate reduction
uh all for yourself if you're interested
in the features that i talked about
before the custom classes or the safe
context
you can apply for alpha access calabar
inside google.com
is how to get in touch with me um
thanks very much and i wish you best of
luck
with all of your speech accuracy
you